[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys welcome to this video
so it's been a while since I made any
content on this channel specifically my
type of content but I'm back today with
a video about the hollow body or what is
sometimes referred to as the dish
position now this is a fundamental
position that acts as a really strong
Foundation to many other disciplines
that can kind of stem from that and it
creates a firm sense of stability and
balance so the way the video is going to
work is I'm going to start by explaining
the benefits of the hollow body and how
that translates to specific activities
and disciplines that you might be
training in next I'm going to
demonstrate the correct technique and
show you some exercises of how you can
improve strength in this area high
performance in most sports and athletic
Endeavors depend on strong and stable
core muscles working in the hollow body
position it can act as a kind of blanket
exercise that will benefit all of the
disciplines that you wish to train in
there after to start with the basics it
goes without saying that the hollow body
builds a strong core overall but it also
trains the transverse abdominis which
are the deepest abdominal muscles
sitting between the ribs and the pelvis
and it essentially tightens this area
Europe as opposed to having that kind of
bloated turtle shell belly that you
often see now this has both a practical
as well as aesthetic function as we're
going to explore in this video but one
of the most important things about
having hollow body strength is it
greatly contributes to things like
prevention of injury to the back due to
the engagement of the rectus abdominis
resulting in what's known as
anti-extension meaning the use of the
flexion muscles to prevent extension
which can be very dangerous when lifting
something heavy as you'll know if you've
seen any of my previous content I'm a
martial arts practitioner and core
strength instability is perhaps the most
important element in Striking prowess
namely correctly utilizing the kinetic
linking principle in which power is
generated first in the legs then travels
up through the body twist through the
hips then goes to the back chest and
shoulders and then finally down the arm
to the strike multiplying that momentum
through all the leverage of the previous
parts and discharging the energy into
the target it's also vital for Grapplers
as well in that they need to maintain
strength in the core while in motion
maintaining stability in one area while
simultaneously providing Motion in
others in Striking specifically if the
core muscles are not strong enough to
contain and try transmute that energy
into the strike afterwards then it's
going to be greatly compromised
especially when striking against
something with a considerable weight to
it think of the body in this scenario
like a vessel for containing water if
there's a hole in the vessel then the
total pressure is going to be less than
it would be if the vessel was intact it
becomes evident when a martial artist
has an underdeveloped core because they
aren't able to apply their full force
and speed into a strike and it falls
apart somewhere in the middle conversely
when somebody has really refined their
striking technique and combine that with
a strong stable and developed core the
strikes take on a whole new dimension
and striking is just one element that's
improved general movement speed will
also be increased particularly the
ability to change direction quickly and
moving and out of range as well as
strike unusual angles something I
practice alongside my basic martial arts
skills is the spot of trickium which is
essentially kind of an acrobatic form of
martial arts expression having that
hollow body strength is vital here in
having sharp controlled and explosive
movements and similar to this along
those same lines other disciplines that
require hollow body strength as a staple
a gymnastics calisthenics and premium
any form of acrobatics it's used in
things like handstand holds as well as
advanced skills such as the planche that
rely heavily on hollow body strength and
also skills such as the l-sit and the
more advanced v-sit requires still
greater hollow body strength and act as
yet another way to improve strength in
this position now before we go on to
discussing the correct hollow body
technique it's important to mention that
simply the act of engaging in your
chosen activity or discipline will build
strength in the area through muscle
adaptation while having a structured
program utilizing a hollow body training
will act as a force multiplier improving
the skills and techniques that you've
already developed
[Music]
hey guys it's me again so here's what
happened I actually committed myself to
a huge number of videos this month and I
woke up on Monday with a swollen
infected saliva gland which was
disgusting that's when Grant kindly
stepped in and offered to take the reins
on this one for me and he's doing a
fantastic job as ever I'm here again now
though and feeling healthy tell you
about today's sponsor fabulous the
number one self-care app for creating
your ideal daily routine and
accomplishing your goals The Fabulous
basically is a habit tracking app so
what you do is you input your ideal
daily routine the habits you want to
follow and then fabulous will track
these for you track your progress
provide you with reminders and tips to
help you keep going for example if you
want to start doing a hollow body on a
daily basis then fabulous is a great way
to ensure you commit to that and this
would be an amazing way holding hollow
body for one to two minutes a day to
really improve your core and your
general fitness and health you also get
curated Journeys created by experts
which essentially introduce you to new
lifestyle habits and changes that have
been proven to improve your wellness and
your health there's a community feature
through circles where you can find
like-minded people provide each other
with encouragement and support So if
you're looking to get healthier and
improve your lifestyle and habits in
2023 what better way to start doing it
start building your ideal daily routine
today and the first 100 members to use
the promo Link in the description down
below will also get 25 off of their
subscription check it out and thanks
once again to Fabulous of sponsoring
this video thanks to grant for making it
and it might not be my place to say this
today but bye for now
[Music]
so now I'm going to take you through the
hollow body position or technique now
it's relatively simple but I just want
to run through all of the different
elements to make sure that you're
executing it correctly now the first
thing that you want to ensure as you lay
yourself back like this the first thing
that we do is we basically lift up the
head like this to about here now what
we're not doing is we're not sitting all
the way up like this okay because we
need that lower back pressed onto the
ground
so as we lift our head up we lift up to
about here and what I do then is I
Engage The Core muscles into that
posterior pelvic tilt and basically
bring in the navel now the way I like to
think about this is Imagine
scrunching up a newspaper so you want to
get those lower muscles scrunching under
first and then all of the rest after
that so what we do there as we've lifted
up that head we lift up to here and then
I'm pushing that lower back down into
the ground you don't want to have a gap
underneath here space between you and
the floor you want to have the upper
part of your butt your lower back and
just the bottom part of your upper body
pressing into the ground and the first
thing that you want to do from here is
lift up the legs to here and then lift
the hands this is a kind of um less
Advanced version if you're struggling
with the technique and then as you get
better at it you want to just slowly
extend the legs until you're in that
full hollow position like this okay or
you can even bring them lower down to
here then from there if you wish to
advance it more you can bring the hands
back like this into more of a dish
position
I'm going to demonstrate some exercises
now that build hollow body strength what
I'm doing here are called X UPS
returning to a neutral position on the
ground you can do the following
exercises from this position or the full
dish for a more advanced variation the
first one is a simple hollow body or
dish hold use a timer on your phone for
20 to 30 seconds
this is the V up keep the legs and arms
as straight as possible and try to fold
the arms past the legs if you can
[Music]
similar to the regular vehicle in the
alternate view up we touch the opposing
hand and foot in the center again try
and keep your legs and arms as straight
as possible
[Music]
this is the hollow Rock I'm offset in my
equilibrium causing a rocking Motion in
One Direction then using the core
muscles to offset that motion and rock
in the other direction
took up raise the knees in a bent
position and meet it with your chest try
to bring your arms past your knees so
you can crunch in tighter
[Music]
you can also assume the hollow body by
protracting the scapula and engaging the
muscles during plank making it more
stable than the regular plank
same thing goes with push-up variations
and holding it throughout as well this
is a good practice in general as often
people begin this way but allow their
back to kind of sag down as they're
pushing up like this rather than keeping
it tight
another variation is to assume the
hollow body when you're hanging
but the variations include the dragon
flag
and the land push-up
so in conclusion hollow body strength is
a vital component that will improve
performance in any athletic Endeavors as
well as also increase other well-being
traits namely training the posterior
pelvic tilt which is a great antidote
for sitting for long periods as many
people do which contributes to the
anterior pelvic tilt anecdotally I
personally do a lot of sitting when
editing videos and things like that but
I have no issues with my back or
anything of that nature and I believe
that that is due to having good core
development through my own training
finally perhaps the biggest benefit is
that it basically makes everything
you're doing in your chosen discipline
easier because you're not having to rely
on as much momentum and basically
muscling through all the movements
you're performing you're essentially
becoming much more efficient at what
you're doing so I hope you enjoyed this
video today guys if you'd like to see
more stuff from me then please head to
my social media channels that will be
appearing on the screen now and I will
see you next time
foreign